hello and welcome to this video playing
national master phantom and
phantom anton oh okay
it's a pretty fun name but i'm
struggling
so the moroxy bind
b6 wow okay that's not really good
honestly
what is he doing here
the issue with b6 is it doesn't help you
in
in any way it's just um
a pretty um yeah in some way useless
move
and if i'd play knight d5 in the future
um after the capture he has got a huge
problem
with the c6 square
so we'll see how it continues okay push
the h
pawn all the way up the board okay so
we get the scenario now with c takes
sometimes e takes is good but tsc takes
is preferable because
this b6 move has given me the c6
weakness to work with
and i've had many games really where
this was
um at the end pretty decisive factor
okay played h3 which was um to be
expected
i wonder if g4 or g3 should be played
g3 is a more normal thing to do so
let's do it i have to be
a little bit careful that this f3
weakness is not hurting me
like tactics tactics somehow
i currently don't see it
but still you have to be careful in some
cases for example bishop a6 is an idea
to
force some sort of okay
okay i have f4 also
which forces knight g4
take that knight c6
okay he wants to go rook c8 next right
that is
probably his intention
this is one of those cases where bishop
a6
is desirable but it looks a little bit
shaky due to
the weak f3 spot like f5
moves like that could be
problematic
what if i play queen d1 threatening f4
um
yeah maybe this is over sophisticated
if that is a word
he just ignores it so is there a
brilliant idea or
did he just blunder no
he did not blunder actually
f4 he takes bishop takes and he still
has knight g4
because d4 is also hanging
that's pretty bad
okay
that renders my queen um i queen uh idea
completely useless the good thing is
that
why it's still better any end game is
better because
h3 is just a weak pawn
let's say queen c8 or so i'm just a lot
better still
but of course that was not my intention
i did not
want to play it like that an idea here
by the way is
g4 and queen f1 to pick up that pawn
okay
g4 this is useful i think
also in the end game f4 for king g3 for
example
nah that's not going to work that's i
don't believe it
um okay so just take twice
so he's got this check
[Music]
and then he's got this check okay
maybe he's got queen to b7 here
queen g8 yeah yeah
am i losing this game that would be
complete joke really
okay i played blade badly of course
so you deserve to lose but it was such
an utterly great position
why doesn't he just take d5
what is the problem with this move
does he have something better this one
okay
knight f3 or maybe
queen takes d5 was already uh
i mean huge that he had this but
maybe he felt that he has something
better i don't know
i mean he was coming from a completely
lost position strategically so i would
be happy to play queen takes d5
oh man
that's just awful
yeah i still had a better ending maybe
g2 was just gone
if i just play it in a different move
order
crazy that's a crazy crazy game
i'm not resigning i'm a bit too
frustrated
to do that just yet
um yeah
i should resign oh man that was
uh i mean losing in the moroxy bind
shows you that you should stop playing
chess really
from that position
i mean the position is like after this
white is strategically winning already
you should just win the game i mean if
you don't believe me
yeah this is like plus one which is this
is modest
really i thought it just it's more but
okay it will get more during the course
of the game because he continued to play
weird stuff so this was
g4 doesn't work i mean not in the sense
that it wins or so because he has
knight g4 as this is hanging
so something like this works for
works for him but okay king f2 and then
he played
uh this insane move f5 which just
straightaway loses
okay i mean black's position is terrible
anyway but f5 is just crazy
so i take twice he plays this
and now i just have to switch on my my
my head
and win the game so queen f1 simply wins
i'm a typical case of stopping
one move too early i was just thinking
now i don't want to go here but after
that you can just resign
because this is gone and then the game
has the end that it should have
it's totally idiotic then he played king
queen g8
which is good of course and now i'm just
in bad shape
and then it just does not take on d5 as
it was and would be normal he goes here
this and here i'm still winning of
course the end game is just winning
because the g2 pawn
will drop and i just have to make it
just play have to play in the right move
order here
f4 and it's over right yeah gets to go
back
bishop f3 and you can resign them
because it's two pawns
for nothing and instead i'm blundering
this away
because yeah that's just totally idiotic
f4 still wins yeah i mean it was really
difficult to not win this game but i
managed
i'm always totally triggered because
this is
um you keep i i mean i'm playing this
opening for right now for like 30 years
and you you keep getting those positions
that win
winning they win it they win on their
own yeah you don't have to do anything
people are just in bad shape they make
some inaccurate moves and then you get a
winning position
so for me mentally this is already over
and this is sometimes a problem because
yeah i mean you still have to like
calculate the odd line
i mean calculate is a strong word for
stuff like queen f1
but um oh man
you know okay
thanks for watching